welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man aka the
fantastic bore aka whack Panther we have
some breaking news on some big
characters that may be appearing in the
MCU sooner than you think and throughout
this video I'm just gonna be breaking
down the new report that we got from
Charles Murphy make sure you subscribe
to the channel for daily breakdowns like
this and don't forget to turn on the
bell to never miss a video otherwise the
kid gets it okay so according to a
report that has just dropped in the last
24 hours
Charles Murphy has said that he has an
inside source that stated that Victor
Von Doom will be an antagonist in the
upcoming film Black Panther 2 if you've
been keeping up to date with rumors
surrounding the film then you'll know
that there were reports that Namor was
said to be the movie's film and whilst
this new report doesn't mention anything
about that no longer being the case it
does certainly ship things about so
apparently Namor will still be in the
film in some form earn our there and
though he may initially start out as a
villain throughout the movie he will go
on an arc that sees him becoming an ally
of T'Challa this is similar to how the
character is often betrayed in comic
books with Namor pretty much being an
antihero at times that often gets put
into conflict with the heroes of the
Marvel Universe due to his opinions
Murphy says that in the film Doom is
looking to expand his empire which will
see him invading parts of Africa
most notably Wakanda this will indeed
put him at odds with BP and if Namor is
a film for the film I can't see him
realizing that the larger threat is doom
unless he will form an alliance with
Wakanda in order to put an end to the
bigger threat now there was mention of
an underwater earthquake in Avengers
endgame off of the coast of Wakanda that
could indeed be highlighting that
something is going on in the ocean and
if this is a setup for Namor and
Atlantis and then later doom I think
he'll be a great way to go the arrival
of doom also heralds the introduction of
the Fantastic Four and though there is
no confirmation on Marvel's first family
making an appearance in the film
if doom is there then I think that this
would be a smart way to bring the
characters into the universe for those
who don't know what Black Panther
actually debuted in Fantastic Four 52
back in 9
in 66 so it would be a nice little
switch up to have them debut in this
film as a way to kind of reference his
first appearance movie states that the
main inspiration for bp2 will be black
panther do more which was a book in
which doom tried to invade Wakanda in
order to obtain vibranium which I can
definitely see being a logical motive
and a cool way to introduce the
character to the Marvel Universe Murphy
did say that this is a rumor for now and
that he has been unable to verify it by
a second source but he does say that the
person that provided him this
information has been right in the past
so as him now just keep your eyes peeled
for updates on the story as we go ahead
now make sure you say look to the
channel for all of the news on the movie
as we get it and obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on this rumor and if
it's something that you'd like to see
also let me know which actor you want to
see play doom and if you enjoy this
video then please give it a thumbs up
and don't forget to check out our
breakdown of the recent chadwick boseman
and Russo brothers film 21 bridges which
would be linked at the end we go over
everything that you need to know about
the movie so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
you want to come chat to me after the
video that make sure you follow me on
twitter at definition whitey right over
to my discord server which should be
linked in the description below we drop
videos on there early so if you want to
see stuff before anyone else and that's
the best place to be it's free to join
and we have an awesome community so
hopefully I see you over there very soon
also giving away a free copy of the
Marvel phase 3 part 2 boxer on blu-ray
which contains Black Panther infinity
war and Game Captain Marvel and more and
all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning is like the video make
sure that you subscribe to the channel
and leave your thoughts on the dr. doom
news in the comments section below the
winners gonna be chosen at random on the
15th of December and the cell be shipped
out from then to ever get surprised it's
the best of luck to everyone who takes
part this is a channel for people who
are super into superheroes so if that's
the kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thank you for taking the time to watch
this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]